if he doesn't go away for something that
people view as morally reprehensible I
think it only increases his star power
oh yeah and the fervor of his fan base
he's already bigger now 100 especially
like let's say he does five years for
tax evasion it's like oh they couldn't
stop him so they had to get him on tax
evasion oh he was too powerful The
Matrix was trying to quiet him it's like
yeah or maybe he was Finding ways to
skirt around taxes and he wasn't you
know bribing the right people in Romania
that's the other thing it's like my man
was talking about how corrupted and he's
like you snitching on yourself say
Romania is not corrupt at all it's the
perfect place and you want people to
move there it's amazing
Romania to prosecute you can't go say
that [ __ ] to millions of people you're
basically going you won't in order to
maintain their reputation they have to
prosecute you almost like wearing the
men coat to the boxing match like yeah
you were doing this [ __ ] silently they
wouldn't give a [ __ ]